♪
I miss you so much.
I miss you too Momma.
Alice: Will you be careful out there?
Always.
♪
Mummy!
Jo: I’m very happy to be back home.
♪
Jo: But things are different.
Jo: I have a piano in my house
♪
Jo: And I don’t play the piano.
Jenny: Do you have hallucinations?
Alice: Momma?
♪
Yeah.
Henry: Astronauts go through things they don’t understand.
That’s when people come unstuck.
♪
Jo: When I was up there,
Jo: the only thing I could focus on
Jo: was getting back to my daughter.
♪
Alice: I miss you mummy, will you be careful up there?
Alice: Mummy who was that?
Jo: That was you and me right before the accident.
♪
That was not me.
Momma?
♪
Where is she?
Who?
♪
You!
Henry: I invented a machine we took into space.
And I saw something.
Henry: But it seems like it doesn’t want to be seen.
♪
Irena: People see things up there.
Irena: And when they get back they go crazy.
♪
This isn’t madness!
Jo: You need to help me!
♪
Jo: I need to go back to her.
Jo: Do I seem the same to you?
♪
I just don’t feel like you’re my mum.